[Music]
on this saturday night pushing the
limits
ontario goes back to full capacity for
major sporting events and concerts is it
too much too soon for other provinces if
we open up um very quickly then what
what is the outcome why restaurants gyms
and other businesses won't see
restrictions lifted just yet
the u.s holds its first face-to-face
talks with the taliban since the
militant groups takeover of afghanistan
plus the pandemic pivot to being your
own boss
kovad forced me like a lot of other
people to take that risk
and the inspiring life of nadia
chaudhary the legacy of a beloved
professor who shared her final journey
with the world
[Music]
global national with robin gill
reporting tonight para nasser
good evening and thank you for joining
us it's the tale of two canadas in the
fourth wave while bc maintains a cap on
sporting arenas theaters and concert
halls those venues are permitted to be
packed in ontario and quebec as both
provinces lift capacity limits as of
today
now while it signals a semblance of the
before times as kamil karmale reports
the move has frustrated many small and
medium-sized businesses who feel they've
once again been left out
[Applause]
it's been a confusing shift for some
businesses i don't understand it ontario
and quebec announcing they're lifting
the attendance cap for major public
spaces like concerts and sporting events
this week but bars and restaurants
remain limited
it's not fair to just again one more
time scapegoating of the restaurant
industry and small businesses
and that also includes ontario gyms for
me it's pretty confusing to be honest
you know we're as safe as any other
place the province of ontario tells
global news restaurants and bars are
higher risk settings prolonged close
contact in enclosed spaces where face
coverings are removed for the entire
duration when seated if restaurants are
also
in the indoor space checking vaccine
records to make sure people who are
dining inside it seems it doesn't make
sense to me
but in british columbia it's the
complete opposite no venue limits in
gyms and restaurants but there is an
attendance cap for concerts and sports
like canucks games vancouver is now the
only team in the nhl not allowed to fill
every seat in their home arena with
seating limited to 50 percent leaving
fans divided i like the capacity limits
i think it's better for the fans and
everything it's a full arena health
experts argue the difference still comes
down to where you live eat and play if
you look at your rates of covert per
capita you're not doing as well in bc
as other provinces are in central or
eastern canada the number of active
covet 19 cases per 100 000 people in bc
is at 124
compare that to ontario which is sitting
at 31. would you start packing stadiums
in bc at this moment you know you got to
see what direction you're headed in the
canucks say they've been in close
contact with public health and are
optimistic they'll be able to hold games
at full capacity by late october
meanwhile the bc government also says
it's planning on making a decision soon
farah
kamal karmali in vancouver thanks kamil
the u.s is now accepting travelers who
received vaccines approved by american
regulators or the world health
organization but it is unclear if having
mixed doses could still be a hurdle for
canadians heading south health minister
patti haidu is on the west block this
weekend mercedes stevenson joins us now
with what's coming up mercedes
faro the federal government is mandating
vaccination for domestic air and rail
travel in canada but there are still
lots of questions about international
travel and what canadians who have
received mixed doses of the covit 19
vaccine will and won't be able to do
under new vaccination requirements being
introduced in countries like the united
states
the u.s does not recognize anyone who
received mixed vaccines for example one
shot of astrazeneca and one of pfizer as
being fully vaccinated that could have a
significant impact for many canadians
who want to travel to the u.s from
snowbirds and vacationers to those
traveling for business or to see family
i spoke with secretary becerra before
the election this is something that i
think all countries are working through
which vaccines will they accept as proof
of vaccination for entry into the
country and we're going to continue to
work with our american counterparts to
share all the data they need to to move
on this issue we'll also talk to the
health minister about when covid
vaccines might be approved for children
in canada something lots of canadians
are talking about as families with kids
gather for thanksgiving there is still
no shot approved for children under 12
in canada and many parents are worried
about another school year that could be
interrupted by covid closures i asked
minister haidu where canada is at in the
process of approving a vaccine for kids
we do know that pfizer has submitted
some data to health canada regulators
but we expect the full package in the
next
week or two and then the regulators will
do what they do which is review all of
that data and evidence
including potentially visiting some of
the manufacturing sites
to assure that they are confident in the
safety data and the efficacy data haidu
also says the health canada review will
likely be expedited to move quickly on
the information that pfizer has provided
we'll also talk about whether canadians
should expect a booster shot and when a
promising covid treatment might be
approved for use here pharah mercedes
stevenson in ottawa thank you mercedes
the village of litton british columbia
went up in flames earlier this year
after days of unprecedented heat
months later hundreds of residents have
yet to return to their homes still
scattered in hotels living with family
members or in one of few houses that are
still standing there global bc's
matagahi visited the town a hundred days
after disaster struck
she doesn't talk about it but her
her behavior definitely shows that she's
stressed
there's no danger
but just about everything surrounding
them is a reminder of that wednesday
afternoon at the end of june i'm
really easily triggered the smell of
smoke
sound of a helicopter anything a
weird-looking cloud especially
the whole town was on fire
you know the reserve was on fire
you know people were running for their
lives
in just minutes hundreds evacuated two
people were killed
now 100 days later many have not
returned because they no longer have a
home here in the days that followed the
disaster government promised to support
and rebuild
those displaced are now frustrated that
the process has been slow disappointing
lots of words not a lot of action
toxicity reports have come back to show
exactly what first responders had warned
about from the get go what was burned in
the fire is extremely hazardous and now
there are delays trying to figure out
how to safely transport the wreckage and
where it could even be disposed so we
have food and hygiene products and
cleaning supplies and anything that you
really need like necessities this is all
a lot of people have right now with no
food store in linton relief centers like
the one here at the scapa first nation
are stepping up to feed people with
donations they've received forestry
helicopters megan fendricks believes her
house was saved by a last second drop
from a helicopter water bucket without
income from her burned business and a
community to rely on
the future for her and five-year-old
helen is completely uncertain
there's no words for it
and also dependent on the rebuild of
linton
emadugahi global news
an indigenous policing model could have
saved rodney levi's life that's
according to his family the mi'kmaq man
was shot fatally by police in new
brunswick last summer
bolstering indigenous policing is among
18 new recommendations for the rcmp they
were issued by a coroner's inquest
looking into levi's case in hopes of
stopping deaths like his from happening
again
ross lord reports
for the levi family finding positives
hasn't been easy their brother rodney
was shot to death by new brunswick rcmp
in june of 2020. he had approached
officers with two large kitchen knives
in an agitated state at a coroner's
inquest family members felt helpless
unable to ask questions because they did
not have legal standing you know it was
a big roller coaster all these eight
days and
i'm just glad today that we could
finally breathe the inquest jury
concluded their brother's death was a
homicide they say it dispels any notions
of a so-called suicide by cop where
people deliberately provoke police into
killing them just remember our brother
and that he did not want to die
the jury calls for the federal
government to reinstate a policing model
in which migma peace officers work with
the rcmp a program people in levi's new
brunswick community say was cut for the
rcmp the jury recommends mandatory first
nation cultural sensitivity training for
cadets dedicated liaison officers at
detachments near first nations
communities and better training for rcfp
officers on crisis intervention and
de-escalation
the inquest heard maudie's currently
receive a three-hour online course in
de-escalation with no practical
exercises scrutiny over how police in
canada interact with indigenous
communities is more intense than ever
after a string of fatal shootings
including single mother chantelle moore
in edmondson new brunswick last year and
jared lowndes a father of two in
campbell river bc in july
levi's family knows the jury's
recommendations are not binding it's up
to the departments to adapt the
recommendations in their in their
organizations in a statement rcmp
headquarters says it will carefully
consider the recommendations which also
include faster national rollout of
body-worn cameras and more detox centers
on first nations reserves levi struggled
with addiction and with mental illness
new brunswick prosecutors cleared the
rcmp officers of any wrongdoing the
question now
is what actions will be taken to prevent
similar confrontations and tragedies in
future
ross lord global news
a u.s delegation is meeting with taliban
leaders in qatar this weekend the first
in-person talks since the u.s military
withdrew from afghanistan the taliban
ruled out helping the u.s keep extremist
groups out of the country the bold
statement comes after a deadly suicide
bombing jennifer johnson reports and a
warning some images here are graphic
afghanistan's violent regime change has
not stopped deadly violence in the
country saturday saw mass funerals for
the 46 people killed in a suicide
bombing at a mosque friday images of the
attack are horrific the shia mosque was
packed for friday prayers
less than 24 hours later the taliban has
told the u.s and western allies it will
not cooperate in ridding afghanistan of
extremists not the compromise u.s
officials wanted but what many afghans
feared and why so many fled their
country i was happy there but
when the tall one came we were in danger
senior taliban rulers are meeting with
diplomats from western countries
including canada this weekend in doha
already dismissing a plan to crack down
on extremist groups isis is seen as the
terror group that poses the greatest
international security threat military
experts say they can organize almost
anywhere the reality is global terrorist
groups like al qaeda or isis can go a
lot of places so afghanistan is not
unique in that standpoint they could
operate from pakistan or somewhere else
also central to this weekend's talks is
the evacuation of additional afghans
especially those who helped allied
forces countries like the u.s and canada
during the war the biden administration
insists that remains a top priority we
of course will continue to
work in partnership with leaders in the
region to work to get
partners who stood by our side out of
afghanistan
for now security in afghanistan remains
very unstable the future for millions as
uncertain as ever
jennifer johnson global news washington
coming up how the rest of the world can
support afghans with the taliban in
power
the pandemic has forced many canadians
to re-evaluate goals and priorities and
this is especially true when it comes to
people's careers and for those who
worked nine to five the stress of the
last 18 months has even pushed some of
them into entrepreneurship and gaviola
looks at the pandemic pivot to become
your own boss
tamara robbins griffith started her own
interior design business during the
pandemic to escape the routine of many
in the regular workforce pre-covid i had
a corporate job with a really long
commute i was always the last mom
picking my kids up from daycare ordering
food for dinner in the car on the way
there you know there just wasn't a lot
of flexibility she says it wasn't an
easy decision and starting her own
company comes with a lot of risk but the
reward is the flexibility she and her
family needed covid forced me like a lot
of other people to take that risk it's
like you have the golden handcuffs of
those corporate benefits that can be
really hard to let go of official date
on the number of people who've decided
to become their own boss during the
pandemic is hard to come by according to
statistics canada the number of new
businesses opening peaked in the summer
of 2020 and entrepreneurship levels have
remained strong at the start of this
year according to the latest jobs
snapshot nearly a quarter million people
are self-employed many of them are
running their own business amy lockwood
had worked in kids media for years the
pandemic left her jobless and without
child care so she started making wooden
toys for fun i started using power tools
and building things and i'm disabled
myself my son and i both have a genetic
disorder that affects all our joints and
all our connective tissue her dabbling
led her to create a line of toys
designed to promote inclusion for people
living with disabilities she launched in
november and hasn't looked back since i
sold out of all my toys
in less than 24 hours
and recouped my initial investment in
the first day being your own boss isn't
for the faint of heart when you have
that
personal stake in the business you're
working hard for yourself not some you
know global multinational to profit from
it but those who've made the leap say
one of the biggest rewards is personal
satisfaction you just don't get from a
regular nine to five ann gaviola global
news toronto
still ahead how a former afghan
ambassador to canada says countries
should engage with the taliban
prime minister justin trudeau is
starting off this thanksgiving weekend
by meeting a family new to canada
trudeau joined community members in
ottawa to connect with his family
recently resettled from afghanistan
including their two young children tudor
then helped volunteers prepare some
thanksgiving food baskets for those in
need in the nation's capital
weeks after the taliban seized power in
afghanistan once again the country faces
total economic collapse and mass
starvation
this week on the new reality the focus
is on afghanistan's women and the
country's future here's donna friesen
with a preview donna
hi farah now that the taliban are in
control the rest of the world has a
decision to make how do we engage or do
we engage with the taliban i put that
question to omar samad he was
afghanistan's ambassador to canada
during the time when our military faced
the heaviest and deadliest action in the
war in afghanistan
do you think
it is right and appropriate for
countries to consider
recognizing the taliban as the
government i think that
in some ways it's simple if they allow a
certain level of freedoms such as media
freedom which actually still exists they
haven't cracked down totally on that
people still get on tv and criticize
them
which is amazing in some ways but
if they continue that
and if they crack down on international
organizations or terrorist groups that
are using afghanistan or want to use
afghanistan whether they're pro
tolerable or anti-talib and crack down
on those elements
whether they're anti-western or whether
they're anti-china or iran or russia
then i think that they will there is
very little room for the rest of the
world not to recognize them do you see
any signs of those kinds of advancements
actually taking place
yes and no and i think the more presence
you have in afghanistan if the
international community is engaged if
the international media is still engaged
if there are some u.n agencies
functioning we would have a window into
afghanistan and we would know what the
taliban are doing and whether they're
changing or not if you shut down and you
close the country and you isolate the
country and you cut
its lifelines then obviously
not only are
we jeopardizing their livelihoods and
the lives of afghans but we are also in
some ways
closing the door and
basically saying you can do whatever you
want and we're not watching and we're
not listening
that and our mike armstrong talks to
women trapped in afghanistan unable to
get out brave enough though to speak out
they say this is not the same country
the taliban overtook in the 1990s and
they refuse to stay silent
farah
thank you donna that's all coming up
tonight on the new reality at 7 p.m
right here on global
remembering professor nadia chaudhary up
next how she bravely faced a deadly
disease giving others wings
[Music]
montreal's nadia chaudhary is one of an
estimated 3 100 canadians who were
diagnosed with ovarian cancer last year
she's touched the lives of nearly 150
000 people around the world by sharing
her palliative care journey on twitter
the concordia university professor
fought to raise ovarian cancer awareness
right up to her death at 43 this week
mike drolla looks at her life and her
legacy
dr nadia choudry never wanted anybody to
mourn her death so in a way concordia
university lured its flags to celebrate
the life of someone who lived to inspire
others all i know is that i'm buying
time and my goal is to buy as much time
as i can when chowdhury spoke with
global news in june she was freshly
returned from a trip to the laurentians
with her son in moon that's what she
called her son and husband she had
become a social media star for her
openness in describing her battle with
terminal ovarian cancer a journey that
weaved between positivity and heartache
in early may she tweeted today is the
day i tell my son i'm dying from cancer
and her thousands of followers cried
along with her you don't have
conversations with death about a
six-year-old
so
these are hard conversations but we have
them now in snippets here and there
and it's good because i want him to be
prepared i don't want him to be
i want him to understand
that
i'll go to a place where my ancestors
are waiting for me
you know and i won't be alone
in hospital she rarely was even if her
legion of supporters had to wait outside
with their nadia gives us wings signs
her research as a neuroscientist focused
on the development of alcohol and drug
addiction but her true passion seemed to
be in mentoring underrepresented
students after all that's who she used
to be she left karachi pakistan at 17 to
study medicine in the u.s
over her last few months she used her
life story as a way to inspire change
and posted videos to spur donations for
a scholarship she had created we'll just
and while it must have been excruciating
she persevered until her body finally
gave out on her but oh what amazing
things she accomplished her wingspan
award raised over 600 thousand dollars
and as a mother she saw the blazing bond
between her son and moon flourish dr
nadia choudry was 43 when she died a
mother a scientist a mentor
an inspiration
mike drolite global news toronto
and that is global national for this
saturday night i'm farah nasser we leave
you with the cherry blossoms in
vancouver an unusual but welcome site
this time of year until tomorrow take
care of yourselves and each other
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]